ok 53 blöcke ich werde jetzt mal ganz
kurz zeit haben um ihre rüstung
ja ja ja mein ganzes eisen verloren weil
ich gerade am kraft
hallo ich meine lieben freunde herzlich
willkommen zu einer weiteren folge
ändert game zusammen mit cohrs hallo
hallo wie geht das hatte eine etwas
längere pause paket das ist jetzt wieder
dass ich damals gesagt wenn ihr jetzt
eine folge auf und gleich werden wir
noch hero aufnehmen was dann bei kinos
kommen wird
und jetzt geht's erst mal los mit ender
games und wie heißt du port wieder
vergessen irgendwie ist wahrscheinlich
töten wir uns einfach gleich mitten in
der medizin in allerdings mal täglich
allerdings allerdings ich hab keinen kit
ausgewähltes wenig redstone ist mit
abstand das schlechteste kit mit dem man
ja spielen kann finde ich okay ich habe
drei gold und mehr nicht
ok ich bekomme doch irgendwie nichts auf
die ich hab tnt und redstone ist ja
schon mal total veraltet von anfang an
jeden fall ich habe nur drei gold mehr
nicht das heißt ich war auf jeden fall
ne kiste ich brauch ein bisschen reisen
einzel habe jeden fall passieren was
will ich denn jetzt springe einfach
alles in die luft
wer bist du denn wie heißt du den moment
ich heute nicht wo ich weiß wie ich heiß
irgendwas mit 5 hinten dran so ich
schreibe meine wurde sieht man das dann
da ja dark shadow play fünf bin ich okay
dass hirsch nicht weiter wurde besten
ich bin ich bin ganz oben ich meine du
wolltest vielleicht erst mal wissen wer
ich bin ich bin der typ die luft sprengt
wie so ein toller mensch ist ein typ
schreibt wenn der gleiche meinung
40 länder tschetschenischen laufe ich
hätte die verschwinden jetzt alle drei
alle drei fahrspuren stimmt youtube
videos sowie verschwindet erste energies
verschwunden
die hier bleibt noch bisschen die denken
ich bleib nach witten
trotzdem brauche endlich schwert
menschheit endet in auffach scheiße ja
ich bin ich bin definitiv gleich tot ich
hab einfach nichts am status irgendwie
ein paar bau redstone sachen und das ist
irgendwie jetzt nicht so nicht so geil
ich versteh ich habe gar nichts am start
ich habe nicht mal eisen oder so wie es
auch dann wieder diese scheiß
unsichtbare wand dächer schreibt mich
immer so heftig wie unsichtbare wand
auftaucht denkmalhof text geht das ich
bin ich bin so unglaublich gut ich bin
im nichts und ich werde da okay es ist
nie ich bin im arsch
ich wurde von games auge tötet ich
wirklich gut geht ich und getäuscht wird
getauscht nicht bar geräumig bei rum und
ich bin immer noch ein spiel auf einmal
plötzlich aber ich lebe für seine kiste
kommt bitte bitte jammert es ist einfach
reisenden geil weil eine schreckliche
entdeckung jürgens engel oder was eine
böse ende konnte ich richtig heftig
nicht richtig böse ende warst du jetzt
mal ein schwert ist für die scouten weil
warten richtig fies dass ich halt gucken
die man kommt nicht so richtig darauf
sharpless ist einer der termine vorkommt
acht männer tot
ich hab mein fröhlich ich weiß der
frieden gezeigt oder nicht zufrieden
gezeigt hat tut mir leid kräftig mensch
was habe ich das immer ein bisschen jura
und so gerne ich habe mal so
teleportation du kannst dir juni vier
blöcke die weg sind das würde ich ganz
oft benutzt man ja sie kommen immer
näher und jetzt läuft er wieder weg
jetzt bleibt bestehen wohl
ich weiß nicht nein mein ja ich hab in
die schweiz zurück wo ich habs grad hoch
geworfene luft hat sich teleportiert
wurde zurück zu dem wochenende conny
junge der nächste spieler von mir 119
blogger entfernt es sind glaube ich auch
gar nicht mehr so viel am start also mit
ihr sind es sechs
sechs menschen und konkreter fünf
menschen konnten
ich habe dabei auf europas drauf ist es
irgendwie gut oder so dass spinnen also
das bringt ja eigentlich grad so mega
bis nichts
cool da habe ich immer wieder richtig
toll kommt ja nachher heute mit den
themen corti graf dazu gast ja der
schlechteste minecraft display ja
überhaupt dinger ich bin grad vor gut ja
wer ist gestorben
ja stimmt gab es sofort gut aber das
sage ich zu jedem so habe ich auf mich
damals bei simon vorgestellt bei uns
gespielt auf dem bett videopreis kam
total gut an
ich bin vielleicht endlich hast hätte
ich auch so genau richtig deswegen haben
wir alle negativ weil in wirklichkeit
sind sie uns immer töten
deswegen hatten wir uns auch alle und
ich suche gegner und du kannst mir
diesmal nicht helfen wenn du mir einfach
sagt wo keine gegner sind sondern ob ihr
irgendwo mainz verlegt
hektische winter jetzt ist wieder gut
okay okay das ist ja auch so gewesen ist
damals auf der gamescom wo zander und
schaffe mir mega aufs maul gehauen haben
wo ich wo ich diese diesen
nasenbeinbruch hatte das ist ja dass das
wissen die meisten dass das für ausmaße
sind die diese unseren hero tod annehmen
also wir treffen uns da wirklich dann
regelmäßig am wochenende und prügeln uns
krankenhausreif so ernst nehmen dass du
letztens war es halt einfach so dass wir
wollten halt traden wir beide ich habe
das labor gegeben dass man ein bisschen
erde hier kommt ein gegner immer näher
hier kommt ein gegner immer näher wie
kommt ein gegner der ski doos guckt mir
zuerst direkt vor denise direkt vorne
ist ich gucke ich gucke zu ich gucke zu
dick oder dünn
möge gewinnen können und er ist einfach
besser als getötet aber ich hatte auch
gar keine ich hatte auch artig rüstungen
an stört dass keine rüstung an das
wollte ich ja nicht gerade sagen dass du
bist du im inventar bauer so keine
angezogen bist du dabei weißt du dass
ich was im
weil du wenn du stirbst dann hinterlässt
du ja die sachen die in einem inventar
sein und da habe ich gesehen ist der
rüstungsteile drin machst du mit dem
traden erzählst du denn der nächsten
runde geht von aus der schnickschnack
direkt schon wie ich mich wieder
einlogge dressieren das nicht bis ich so
einen sohn schneider sondern gehst du 9
ich bin ne 1919 bin ich drin genau kann
ich natürlich been big easy 99 ich bin
der block a 15 klingt wie der name für
ein handspiel aber dass das bin ich
wieder vampir nehmen ich gucke ich gucke
was ich nehme ich glaube ich nehme
einfach hier den den gut jetzt habe ich
aber auch jedes jahr gebraucht
auszuwählen toll hast du das gemacht
dass man fängt doch alle scheiterten
hier
ich bin irgendwas ich ganze gleich sagen
überraschungseffekt ich bin skorpion
wo siehst du da warst du bist ja das
steht dann da wenn du nichts aus wählt
dann bekommst du so ein zufalls
generiert das kit und das steht am
anfang der runde so bald wieder auf
diesem platz wo stehst steht dann da du
bist skorpione oder reize wie heiß das
steht auch ganz am anfang da ich bin
block a 15
das hab ich doch gesagt ich bin die 99 8
ist das brettspiel ich bin das brechen
genau am flughafen nicht wo du
tatsächlich ist aber ich hoffe mal dass
ich sie bekommen jetzt zwei eisen
ich bekomme mal wieder nur knapp aber
immerhin irgendwas das fleisch fleisch
geklaut welcher schön so was mir bleibt
clown kannibalistische erstmal
auseinandergenommen
ich habe einen kuchen bin ich jetzt cool
nein mein körper hat schon wieder man
jetzt gehts ja
es liegt doch eigentlich nur an einer
internetverbindung vereine zusammen
internetverbindung also es ist wirklich
asozialen ich mich schrecklich sagt
jedoch zu jedem habe ich auch simon
gesagt dass ihn gesehen habe mannichl
wieder in kisten das bringen wir mal
eine ja ich sehe auch comics ich habe
auch nichts ich hab sechsfache unten
switcher ja super und 1 gold block und
unten und wie gesagt kuchen auf den
kuchen bin ich sehr stolz
ja das ist so mit abstand das dass das
beste was ich in den letzten paar tagen
erreicht habe
das hat etwas mit dem mit dem mit dem
sonntag zu tun an dem coni und ich
zusammen weg waren zwar wunderschön dass
wir das am sonntag gemacht dann vieles
vieles wieder mit dem weg du da bleibt
nichts nicht so ausgelassen
da bleibt leider nichts tun angekotzt
könnte man sagen jedoch zurück ich bin
ich bin tot gestorben von notebooks
gedrückt gibt getröstet getötet
natürlich selbst getötet getrödelt ich
jetzt nicht war oder ich frage mich am
anfang sogar noch kannst du denn
ja ich brannte es dann eigentlich auch
nicht wenn ich mit ihr spiel du bist so
sexy du längst mich viel zu sehr ab weil
du mich auch sie ist komplett anderen
namen hängen gerne habe advent meine
stimme einfach nein ich meine nicht mal
deine stimme ich muss auch wirklich
während immer während ich mit konkreter
aufgabe habe ich muss sich währenddessen
zwanghaft masturbieren ich bin das ist
einfach die andere an der hose und dann
muss einfach deswegen steht es doch
immer so schnell weil damit eine hand
spielst du aufgeregt deswegen darf ich
bei aufnahme die auch nie die face
karmann machen weil sonst würde man eher
sander und so wackelt ja seine grimassen
dann also was richtig deswegen ab sofort
in ich hab das jetzt zu gehen bei den
älteren aufnahmen habe ich mich nur
beherrscht kann aber inzwischen geht das
einfach nicht mehr die die liebe ist zu
groß die neurose ebenso und deswegen ab
sofort bei jedem aufnahmen mit contracts
bei mir keine feste mehr weil sonst wird
man sehen wie
die subtile weise wie sind die beiden
schlechtesten
dies gilt übrigens die nato getötet ich
glaube da durcheinander der vorherigen
aufnahmen die nicht im video drin sind
auch schon weg geschnippelt ja es war
nämlich immer so wir stehen da es gibt
keinen kampf beim energie man eg 17
es gibt keinen kampf bei mir wo ich
direkt auf den spieler zu laufen und wir
uns boxen
es ist immer so dass sie von hinten
kommen oder irgendwie von der seite und
ich nicht sehe
obwohl wohin mein ding noch meinte 27
blockes davon die weg da krieg ich eine
sekunde weg auf einmal direkt neben dem
abgrund klasse ich mir jetzt mal andere
klasse dass er genau für mich die klasse
oder der suppen meister startet mit fünf
mann bekommt ich pilzen jeweils drei
leben regeneriert das hat er auch
genannt
der holzfäller scheint mit einer holz
eisen kann einbäume staatsleistungen
meister nein ich bin ich dass ich bin
der papa auch so kommt das passt ich
denke ich bin jetzt übrigens auch ohne
belag der hätte den holzfäller jetzt
holzfäller ja ich bin jetzt auch ob ich
bin besten mobbing ist besten mobbing
schön wo nächsten url lac du ich hüpfe
in der mitte und ich glaube leute die
denken ich wäre du wahrscheinlich vorher
wussten dass du da jetzt einfach direkt
tot aber das ja nichts neues
wir nehmen sie auch ich wir sind mitten
im thema ach ja ich bin übrigens tot
das passiert immer schon drei sätze
vorher aber das passiert einfach direkt
am start wieder unterbrechen
meine meine eigene unterhaltung ist
einfach eine viel höhere priorität in
dieser aufnahme ja moment ich muss kurz
abspritzen bei der besten chance diesmal
länger leben ich liebe solche leute wie
mich der danke
pastor ich auch besser wenn dann geht da
wären nicht so mies loops ich liefere
glücklich ist dazu eingefallen was ich
warum
irgendwie wollte ich mal anbringen so
zehn sekunden kinos das ist zeichen und
das ding da vergessen kinos oder die
verwechseln schon geil da wollte ich
wollte ich nicht über männliche
genitalien in trance popo reden das
hatte man gar nicht nötig so viele kitas
wieder jedes wochenende begründet jetzt
weiß ich gar nicht mehr wie ich mich aus
diesem schlechten witz rausreden weil ja
nicht gelacht hat ja das ist es
irgendwie schwierig also eric wir wissen
ja wir sind wir sind beide street habe
den holzfäller und kann jetzt direkt
abfällen daraus du bist du bist der berg
der mit schlechthin doch nicht noch kann
ich nicht jedoch kann ich jedoch so ich
muss auf jeden fall eine kiste in die
kiste ja jetzt wieder zwei die wenigsten
wissen der conny der küst wirklich
richtig schlapp regt das ist echt so ein
bisschen aus wie ein schnabel hinein und
sich an gut küssen
das muss auch mal bezeugen jetzt wär wär
bestätigt mir dass deine oma bereich
wieder am ende der welt liegt mir zu
meiner mutter wissen willst du willst du
gehen willst du meine mutter disney
ich würdige man immer und ich mache die
kaputt ich bin hier echt hart an der
welt jetzt kommt das wird jetzt redet er
wird über wasser immer wenn sich der
kontrakt nicht zu helfen war es dann
fängt davon von kubus an das stimmt ganz
miese nummer aller dieser alle von mir
60 platten verteilt ja eigentlich kann
mir nichts passieren aber wir sind auch
alle recht weit weg aber ich bin noch
ein bisschen ich habe verdammt viele
wassereimer und milch ich habe mich
immer gut spielen
ich höre auch schon wieder hier 33
blöcke nur noch 18
er kommt mit schnellen schritten auf
dich zu teleportiert 70 70 73 76 74 das
problem ist ja man wird ja meistens wird
wenn man oder ist minecraft kill 3 den
würde ich mal weg da das erledigt ich
habe viel gemacht da soll mal jemand
sagen ich will dass du hast du gemacht
ja ich hab mein jetzt habe ich auf mich
also zwei kopien boxen bisschen dumm
aber ist okay es okay ich bin ich komme
damit klar blöd zu sein
eine kiste voll mit sachen zurück zu
meinem crafting table nach denen ich
auch vor dem inventar habe ich habe gar
keine lust hast du die asse uni lustiges
zu kräften irgendwie für diesen fall
keinen bock auf minecraft er richtig
scheiße ich hatte mein kraft spiel ja
ich hatte es auch sachen zu kräften
richtig eklig findet von anstrengend das
ist ja genau so ok 53 blöcke ich werde
jetzt mal ganz kurz zeit haben mir hin
zu rüsten
ja ja ich habe mein ganzes eisen
verloren weil ich gerade am kräften
wurde kraft gefordert die ja ich hatte
14 eigentlich die komplette liste machen
können aber ich habe ziemlich führung
ging dadurch gerade bekommen also gold
zeigt scheiß gewöhnt ich meine ruhe
kräften putz geortet wurde getauscht mit
du wurdest mit kleber mit alles
getauscht minute für dich irgendwie mit
dem a4 herzen kairos war ich einfach
nichts zu essen habe und da hätte ich
mir eine rüstung gemacht wann ich ja
gemacht habe wo man einfach getötet
so jetzt hab ich mit gold ich glaube ich
müsste meine sachen liegen außer der der
fritzl hat sich zeit mitgenommen
der fritz fritz jauss der ritze ich
warte wo ich den gebaut und werde auf
einen hohen turm ich fahr runter und bin
wieder althoff auch es ist doch einfach
das kann auch nicht sein hier ne nein
nicht schon blöd ist behinderte 760
spieltag wurde getötet
fast fast hatte ich ihn ganz sicher
ich war fast hast auch du ich bin weil
ich das gefühl das auch richtig gut
kommt ihm auch essen
du brauchst also essen als
entschuldigung mit tulpen jetzt kommt
auch noch eine undo ich werde nicht mehr
er kann als ich sein hier mein leben
muss ich halt noch generieren
du bleibst da oben besser ist das baby
da oben moment wo man nicht ganz so ich
gehe mal ich bin mal eine runde gucken
da oben rum es ist sie bei 717 oder ist
100 meter ist eine hinter seiner hinter
mir ich habe noch
und attacke jedoch vor allem die
situation
du hast einfach 14 eisen kannst den
brustpanzer hose machen und du willst
gerade dabei dazu kräften hat es in den
kräften cable drin war vielleicht zu
zehn sekunden dauert und derzeit wird
einfach gebaute tja es passiert
irgendwie immer im kräftig table also
dass ich das
das gefällt mir gar nicht da möchte ich
es mal nicht so nebenbei den gome
persönlich beleidigen
fick dich dieses spiel erregt nicht zur
zeit mehr auf als flecki bird ich hab
das übrigens angefangen wegen da ich
wegen dein video ich kann es davor schon
habe ich hab ein video gesehen dass sie
mir so 25 schlage ich direkt und nicht
irgendwann denkt wirklich eines spiels
so dass ihr einfach aber es ist nicht
schwer
ja ich bin auf 45 oder so monika mack
fenster zeit mein highscores glaube ich
auch 45 oder vier und 443 irgendwie so
um den dreh selbst das schau mal also es
macht ja auch wirklich ist er schon
sucht machen das ding star jetzt muss
ich jetzt mit kurze runde spielen mache
auf jeden fall ton an
heinz gestorben
als teil 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 schon
christian ii jetzt steht das sind 1000
1000 17 mal einfach so einfach einfach
so ein cut weißt du ich dann plötzlich
so wird stunden später
wie viel hat sie jetzt ob 18 und hatte
ich mal auch ein scheitern abwenden wenn
wir diese aufnahmen ihrer kollegin hat
mama ich hier heute direkt raus hier bei
ihm freunde los geht's 133 jan o also
mein highschools 45 hier in einer cam da
seht der 45-jährigen gleichen highscore
49 auch mal gucken 646 ist mein score
also plötzlich einfach einfach weiter
als ich die kommentare nicht gefallen
hat dass eine bewertung da und schaut
auf ihr paket aus vorbei der auch in
einer beschreibung ist jetzt die dinge
die mir nie wieder gemacht hat hallo
wo es jetzt